you are a very smart guy okay yeah thank
you and i am i have nothing to do with
your intellect
the content thank you for the compliment
yeah do you ever get nervous now that
you do you are a dad
like and you say i'm just going to be
myself i'm going to say whatever i don't
care what people think do you ever
think about the repercussions
for
your kids later on in life
why because people are going to hate me
and then like blame my kids or maybe i
think i think about that i think about
whatever i say
if i say something wrong or that people
disapprove of how would that then
affect showing up at the school with
your kid and well here's the here's what
we do first of all we're public figures
which is already scary i mean people
there's youtubers where people coming to
their house a few years ago there was a
there was a psycho that drove cross
country
and by the way these youtubers whose
house you drove to were clean as it gets
they were like science they had nothing
to do with any controversy he drove to
the house because he was like in love
with the wife and went into the house
started shooting up the house they hid
in the closet the police come and killed
him in the driveway another youtuber was
shot in the head at a meet and greet by
a psychotic fan she was clean she was
just a singer so like the world is
already scary and [ __ ] weird and
there's a ton of people online that hate
me regardless of how people have always
hated me before even i was like more
politically active which is where most
of the hate comes from but here's what i
do i live in a gated community thank god
i have the resources to live
in a place that has good security you
know it was scary
scarier when you know i was
let's say famous and had less resources
to protect
my family but now i do my son goes to a
private school we don't show his face by
the way so people don't know what he
looks like to each other yeah no he
wears a mask all the way around the
house top secret yeah so he's like
blanking we don't put him in video
exactly
we don't put him in videos or we don't
show his face at least
and he goes to a private school with
lots of guards and our house is secure
so you know that's what i do i can't
control
i don't think what i'm saying is that
nuts i really don't here's what i'm
here's what i uh and and and we can get
i'm not like a
tour like i know you're not but the
world is like you're saying the world is
[ __ ] up the world we live in is [ __ ]
up that when you tell those stories
about somebody driving across the
country with a gun because he likes the
couple he was obsessed with him so
that's what he is so when you do
something that is
let's for all intents and purposes just
call it honest thought
you know you you ratchet that up just a
little bit
right
right ratchet what up the uh the danger
of um triggering something i'm gonna
play devil's advocate a little bit
though because then you can't say
anything
right because there's always gonna be
those people out there i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna be myself i can't live in fear
that some psycho was well you're a lucky
guy that your wife is an israeli soldier
so she's got to be really tough trust me
if someone breaks in the house i'm that
i'm the idiot that's going to go
downstairs and get stabbed
really really
she was a secretary no i'm not gonna let
her go down there
my husband would let me go downstairs
yeah yeah my husband would be like
there's a noise you go
that's feminism
he's a feminist yeah
he's giving you equal opportunity
[Music]